الشرطه وين الشرطه عشان تتامن المحلات
عشان المواطن يقدر يتحرك اين الشرطه لسانه
حال المواطن السوداني خاصه في العاصمه
الخرطوم الاكثر اكتضاضا بالسكان في
السودان
التساؤلات عادت خاصه مع تزايد عمليات
السلب للمنازل والمحلات التجاريه ما اجبر
كثيرين على لزوم منازلهم
يتفتح
وجار العسجد
المجوهرات ده برضو يتفتحوا ننضف نظافه
جديده السجون ايضا لم تسلم من حاله غياب
الامن عده سجون فتحت ابوابها والسجناء
كسروا قيودهم
تماما لا عنده مويه لا عنده اكل في ناس في
الجوع والعطش
فقد السيطره تماما
مصادر في سجن كوبر من جانبها قالت ان فتح
السجن عائد لعدم توفر الامدادات الغذائيه
للسجناء وخوفا على سلامتهم وفي الشارع
الخالي يتساءل السودانيون رغم صدور اوامر
من الشرطه لعناصرها عند بدايه الازمه
بالحضور الى اقرب مركز امني
حراميه نحن سودانيين
يدك على حق غيرك لانه الناس الشعب
السوداني تعب لانه حاصل غلاء في الوطن
السودان فيه غلاء شديد لا فيه مويه لا في
كهرباء الناس متجهه لبخاع السودان نسبه
الضيق المعيشه في البلد وعدم توفر الامان
ما شايف شرطي واحد في الشارع لو نزلت
الشرطه امنتوا المواطنين نزلتو البنزين
نزلته كل الناس حترتاح
العنصريه نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط
ونتكلم عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني
محترم لا يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق
غيره نتكلم عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت
في المحنه دي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات